a Lizbeth Guerrero abogada y cofundadora
directora de la organización apoyo a
migrantes venezolanos Lizbeth bienvenida
Franz 24 cuéntanos cuales actualmente la
situación de los venezolanos que han
sido devueltos de Estados Unidos o no
han podido Ingresar a este país
Hola buenas noches gracias por la
invitación sí efectivamente hay una
situación bastante complicada en estos
momentos en México este porque son
bastantes los venezolanos estima al
momento 18.000 venezolanos que han
quedado parados o que han sido devueltos
de Estados Unidos
ahora cómo ha sido el trato de las
autoridades mexicanas y de la población
en general
de las autoridades mexicanas nosotros
las organizaciones este nos encontramos
pero nos hemos dado cuenta de que
efectivamente se tomó una decisión sin
medir las consecuencias de esta decisión
sobrepasó los límites que el mismo
México esperaba que pasaría y
efectivamente no hay una recepción buena
para la gente que está haciendo de
vuelta o la gente que se quedó varada
Por eso hay personas que todavía se
encuentran en situación de calle donde
no tienen atención sobre todo en Estados
fuera de Ciudad de México